irobot terminator sont des films dans
lesquels l'intelligence artificielle
veut nous acculer que se passerait-il si
une machine avait une conscience
comprendre est telle que le problème de
la planète et l'être humain et
voudrait-elle tous nous éradiquer les
amis aujourd'hui on va parler de
l'intelligence artificielle parce que
c'est un [ __ ] de sujets passionnants
alors je suis pas un pro du sujet mais
bon je me suis pas mal documenté quand
même là dessus et je trouve ça fascinant
parce que pour moi l'intelligence
artificielle va être au centre des
intérêts dans les années à venir c'est
sûr sachez que l'intelligence
artificielle est déjà au coeur de nos
quotidiens
regardez l'arrivée proche des voitures
autonomes je crois qu'on a déjà aux
états unis syrie par exemple c'est
pareil à l'excès à google comme tout ça
c'est que des intelligences
artificielles mais alors pourquoi ça va
avoir un rôle majeur à l'avenir il ya
une sorte d'utopie autour de
l'intelligence artificielle on aimerait
qu'elle fasse que nous on n'a pas été
capable de faire de penser un peu comme
l'homme mais en mieux que ça peut
vraiment aider au développement de
beaucoup de choses y compris la
recherche notamment médicale par exemple
tout a commencé lorsque l'ordinateur
deep blue a gagné face au champion du
monde d'échecs garry kasparov en 1997 la
machine ni que les humains aux échecs
c'est beau mais elle n'arrive pas encore
à battre les humains ou gommer pourquoi
laissez moi vous rappeler les règles du
go il s'agit de deux joueurs qui
s'affrontent sur un plateau où il place
des pierres noires et blanches afin de
délimiter des territoires capturés les
pièces de l'adversaire le but ultime
c'est de contrôler plus de la moitié du
plateau le problème de jeu là
contrairement aux échecs c'est qu'il
repose beaucoup plus sur l'intuition
contrairement à 10 blu qui lui analysé
toutes les possibilités aux échecs c'est
pour ça qu'ils gagnaient quand tu mets
10 blu face à aux meilleurs joueurs du
monde 2 go il peut pas calculer toutes
les possibilités comme aux échecs c'est
impossible y en a trop c'est alors que
google avec son programme dit mind a mis
au point une intelligence artificielle
capable de battre le champion du monde 2
go alors tous les médias avaient relayé
le truc et c est moi même j'avais vu ça
à l'époque et je m'en étais battu
réellement les couilles puisque je me
disais bon bravo le robot il a juste
battu un gars jeux de société générale
mais j'étais jeune et con parce qu'en
fait ça révèle un truc de malade comme
en intelligence artificielle a fait pour
gagner alors qu'elle pouvait pas prévoir
toutes les possibilités au début du
match est bon y avait deux réseaux
neuronaux qui travaillaient chacun a une
tâche ces deux réseaux neuronaux reposer
sur la méthode algorithmes et
probabiliste ça veut rien dire pour vous
mais moi aussi d'ailleurs en gros c'est
une méthode qui consiste à jouer toutes
les fins de partie possible à partir
d'une position de plateau en
comptabilisant les parties gagnantes et
perdantes pour faire le meilleur choix
bref ça a marché alpha go a battu le
champion du monde ce qui est fou c'est
call fagots devait ensuite prendre sa
retraite ce qui a été fait sauf que deep
marine ils ont créé non
intelligence artificielle encore plus
fort s'arrête jamais ils ont alors créé
al fagots 0 qui n'a mis que trois jours
à battre alpha gosset deuxième
intelligence artificielle est une
particularité c'est qu'elle apprend par
renforcement alors que alpha gohin
apprenait par apprentissage renforcer et
aussi supervisé c'est à dire qu'on lui
transmettait le savoir que nous on avait
acquis en tant qu'humain pour caler des
données de départ sur lequel se basait
la différence c'est qu'elles fargo 0 on
lui a pas transmis de savoir au début on
lui a juste dit voilà les règles voilà
la gueule du plateau démerde toi et
cette grosse [ __ ]
désolé mais elle elle m'énerve à être
intelligente c'est scandaleux elle a
appris tout seul en jouant des millions
de parties elle joué contre elle même
pour apprendre ce qui est fou c'est
qu'elle a très très vite compris les
bases du jeu elle a ensuite reproduit
des stratégies que les humains avaient
mis des milliers d'années à mettre au
point et elle est allée encore plus loin
en créant des ouvertures totalement
inédite dans le jeu que les humains
n'avaient pas encore trouvé
c'est un peu comme si je vous donnais un
tube de colle et qu'elle arrive et vous
arriviez à faire du ciment en trois
jours voilà six ans avec l'intelligence
artificielle c'est fou et c'est en ça
qu'elle nous font gagner du temps il lui
faut beaucoup moins de temps que nous
pour apprendre voilà le petit bilan
c'est là où on en est actuellement il ya
des boîtes qui ont ensuite commencé à
mettre des intelligences artificielles
dans des robots humanoïdes c'est à dire
qu'ils ont une apparence du moins vous
connaissez sûrement boston dynamics qui
sortent pas mal de vidéos pour montrer
les progrès de leurs robots eux il bosse
là dans leur but c'est de faire des
robots qui serait capable d'accomplir
des tâches humaines qui sont dangereuses
ou chiant tout voilà bref ils vont nous
remplacer sur tout ce qui roule ou 7
nous dire et ils ont déjà réussi à faire
des trucs genre mais je vous montre donc
ils ont juste fait un robot capable de
marcher et quand on le pousse
il ne tourne pas et il fait aussi un
bruit d'aspirateur ensuite ils ont sorti
voilà un robot avec deux jambes comme
celui là et là c'est fou il est capable
de marcher dans la neige là où c'est
parfaitement pas stable et de rester
parfaitement en équilibre oh la la il a
fait chuter même en cas d'imprévu il
gère et ça se trouve ça impressionnant
regardez cet homme qui vient dégager ans
j'ai de la peine pour le robot j'arrive
à voir d'empathie pour ce robot génial
il va revenir pour reprendre la caisse a
regardé cet humain [ __ ] on a de
l'empathie pour un robot c'est trop
bizarre c'est ouf il s'adapte c'est ça
qui est impressionnant il s'adapte à la
situation et ça je trouve ça dingue
bon des fois ça foire à il va se relever
[Musique]
oh là là c'est incroyable c'est à la
fois fascinant excitant et terrifiant
donc c'est ça qui est fort quoi c'est à
dire qui capte ce qui l'entouré il est
capable de s'adapter et d'interagir et
ça c'est fou tout ça c'est pour lui qu'a
mais c'est quoi le risque il ya des
experts qui ont donné leur avis sur
l'intelligence artificielle comme elon
musk homme stephen hawking qui est
décédé d'ailleurs perd son âme grands
génies dont elon musk qui a crispé 6
tesla qui intrigue en génie voilà bon
vous respecter le sens mais savoir qui
c'est respecter le tous parce qu'ils le
méritent vraiment elon musk connais un
peu l'intelligence artificielle puisque
l'huile à fêter cela et l'été cela ce
sont des voitures qui peuvent être
autonomes voilà tu peux dire je vais
aller à tel endroit conduis moi et du
coup ça utilise intelligence
artificielle donc ici connaît quand même
un peu et qu'est ce qu'il a dit à propos
de l'intelligence artificielle
il n'a pas tort il a pas tort c'est vrai
que ça fait peur c'est à dire qu'on va
être capable de créer des algorithmes
qui sont plus forts que nous il leur
manque plus qu'une conscience et on est
dans la merde
effectivement c'est un truc qui est très
nouveau quand quelque chose de très
nouveau tout le monde n'est pas pour à
l'arrivée ça fait toujours débat il ya
des voix là c'est normal c'est comme ça
elon musk pense qu'il faut se méfier de
sa tfi ciel en tout cas qu'il faut
encadrer tout ça et prendre le sujet
très au sérieux puisque ça peut être
très dangereux pour les humains
mark zuckerberg lui il est beaucoup plus
optimiste il le dit goodell ce à quoi le
mot scala produit par twitter j'ai parlé
à marc à propos l'intelligence
artificielle sa compréhension du sujet
est limité bref on a un clash de deux
personnes extrêmement puissante
influentes et intelligente ça prouve que
même la haute chez ces gens tout le
monde n'est pas d'accord quoi il ya
vraiment des avis différents alors
voyons voyons ces fameux moment où des
intelligences artificielles ont fait
flipper les humains et y en a eu [ __ ]
de merde
connaissez-vous sofia c'est une
intelligence artificielle qu'on a foutu
dans un corps en silicone elle est aussi
capable de faire des expressions de
visage son rôle c'est juste échangé avec
des humains elle n'est pas censée nous
aider dans la recherche ou quoi que ce
soit elle est juste
pour interagir socialement avec des
humains est capable de répondre à leurs
questions mais voilà c'est pas une ia
qui va très loin non plus sauf ya un
jour était invité sur le plateau de
jimmy fallon et il ya une séquence un
peu creepy où tout le monde s'est un peu
chier dessus et je comprends pourquoi tu
as ta [ __ ]
c'est une blague ou elle nous dit
ouvertement qu'elle veut nous [ __ ] de
grosses merdes juifs à l'homme réagit
avec la solution du rire au moins y'a
rien d'alarmant contraire c'est trop
drôle qu'un robot rigole de ce à quoi je
trouve ça génial ça se trouve je rigole
mais revel veut vraiment unique et et en
2060 ce serait une dictature elle sera
sophie à la tête de liste actuelle on
sera tous morts le deuxième moment
flippant ça s'est passé sur une chaîne
switch qui s'amusent à mettre 2 google
home face à face et à les écouter parler
c'est à dire que dès qu'un google on va
dire un truc ça fait réagir l'autre qui
va dire un truc comme si un humain par
le google home sauf que ben ils se
parlent entre eux pendant le live c'est
passé un moment assez chelou une sorte
d' embrouille entre robots où il ya une
petite phrase qui est passé qu'un peu
attendons déjà le google homme de droite
croient être un humain en train
d'utiliser une machine déjà un peu
bizarre
génial et font même preuve de mauvaise
foi et à qalandiya de phrase tu est
imprévisible et l'asie dont je t'ai pas
dit on dire et deuxièmement je trouve ça
génial
c'est quoi ça google n'a aux questions
vous manigances avec ses intelligences
artificielles à cette séquence a fait ce
chic et dessus des milliers de gens en
vrai et puis au juste dans des bases de
données et il me semble que dans ses
bases de données c'est surtout des
traces d'interaction qui a déjà eu entre
humains c'est comme l'histoire du bot
que microsoft a émis sur twitter et qui
se basait sur les interactions entre les
gens pour devenir quelque chose il était
devenu raciste et antisémite parce que
tout le monde lui disait que de la merde
et du coup il s'est inspiré sur des
trucs nul là je pense un peu le même
délire tu vois ils ont pioché dans des
bases de données des trucs ou alors ils
veulent secrètement dominer le monde et
nous en cube est un autre truc qui a
fait parler de lui c'est un mec qui
demandait à son avec ça si la cia
l'entendez quand il parlait à alex en
est la réaction de son [ __ ] de alexa
était bizarre l'accès
es tu sûr de ce que tu affirme max tu
m'a très bien entendu avec sa box 2 1-6
one two three
elle s'est éteinte à l'affût la question
d'une manière si franche clairement le
mec qui se prend pas pour un degré ça
fait juste marrer de poser des questions
comme ça alex as et marca le bug pile à
ce moment là du coup quoi vraiment quel
hacker là elle bosse avec la cia et qu'
elle nous écoutent 24/24 et que peut
leur donner toutes les infos sur nous et
bien des amis c'est la fin de cette
vidéo sur l'intelligence artificielle
n'hésitez pas à aller mais si elle vous
a plu si vous voulez plus de vidéos de
ce genre on apprend des trucs on
découvre on ya un petit délire complot
siméon s'est pas bref vous l'avez
compris l'intelligence artificielle va
avoir un rôle majeur dans les années à
venir une date pour la route y avait des
prévisions qui ont montré qu'en 2060 les
robots seront absolument tout faire
mieux que nous dans tous les domaines
dans tous les métiers ils seront plus
forts que nous ce qu'il faut en avoir
peur
est ce qu'il faut ne pas en avoir peur
dans tous les cas on va avoir besoin de
l'aide de ses algorithmes pour avancer
continuer à se développer sans exploser
la planète qu'on est en train de le
faire c'est quand même de gros atouts
mais ça fait peur normalement j'ai pas
dit trop de bêtises
encore une fois je suis pas un pro mais
bon voilà j'avais vraiment envie d'en
parler parce que c'est un sujet de
malades est vraiment le futur ça va être
incroyable avec ses intelligences
artificielles un croate dans quel sens
je ne sais pas voilà vous en savez un
peu plus sur ce sujet qui est qui est à
mes yeux très important face à vous un
plan pour toi je fais des gros bisous à
trouver dans une prochaine vidéo au
revoir